damit der dampf aber hollywood wasser
denn feuer ernsthaft 12
diesmal diesmal schaffen muss auf jeden
fall ist er berühmt berüchtigte jetzt ja
auch geschafft oder erledigt wird es
auch geschafft
helene werden
doch hört ihr könnt euch also dann
scheint es auch los fünf minuten jetzt
soll ihre freunde
heute bin ich es wieder nicht weil ich
es möchte ist soll man welch gezwungen
werde
deswegen werde hätten ganz ganz
einfaches rezept machen wenigstens
eigentlich kartoffel muffins ich jetzt
kartoffel mache jetzt ganz einfach oder
okay was wollen wir zuerst natürlich wir
brauchen kartoffeln und zwar sind es
wirklich pelzer kartoffeln ist die
fenster sind schon zehn tore und
kartoffel jahr ist liegt haft kartoffeln
und das heißt in kenntnis spruch die
dümmsten bauern haben die besten
kartoffeln die dicksten ja die dicksten
marius hat übrigens ganz tolle dicke
kartoffeln im daten größten hat er okay
kartoffeln brauchen wir und zwar neben
mir einfach jetzt kommt nun auf eure
machen kommen natürlich an aber ich habe
hier zum beispiel 12 martin vorn das
heißt ja mit sechs große kartoffeln
genommen dann brauche ich parmesankäse
am stück dann brauche ich hier thymian
und hier ist es ein kräuter am hessen
knoblauch und knoblauch salz genau
worauf sein missbrauchen
dann legen gleich los das erste die
kartoffeln putzen und schälen und dafür
hab ich ein ganz coolen trick den hab
ich mir selber ausgedacht und zwar zeigt
euch das mal ganz kurz
was machst du in der maschine jetzt ja
warum
weil ich kann sagen warum hier eine ganz
ganz tolles gadget das ist auch sehr
sparsam und zeigen wie es funktioniert
ich finde es einfach nicht wasser ich
hab das ungefähr ein drittel mit wasser
gefüllt jetzt die maschine ein deckel
weg
ich glaub du musst den deckel noch nehme
ich dir einen deckel ja ach so danke
meine liebe assistentin die andrea den
decke genau stimmt also obst jetzt ist
es ja auch noch
also ich mach das nicht oft aber es
funktioniert nur die kartoffeln reis
habe zu wenig kartoffeln ich glaube
nicht
wahnsinn oder
jetzt werden die kartoffel gleichzeitig
gewaschen und geschält und ist auch mit
viel wasser ist auch nicht viel wasser
drin das heißt die kann man wirklich
wasser sparen jetzt lass die mal laufen
nicht so schnell
und am rand von diesem gefäß in oben
dran und die noppen die reifen jetzt die
ganze schale weg wahnsinn ist ja ganz
klar
[Musik]
mario ist richtig erkannt das war der
fehler
ich habe es ja gleich gesagt es ist zu
viel wasser so jetzt wird es noch
sparsamer jetzt nämlich weniger
österreich wahnsinn was ihm jetzt
gespart haben jetzt immer noch eine
kartoffel ich glaube ich bin noch eine
kartoffel ist hier mein kameraassistent
dankeschön sondern dicke wieder drauf
und lass uns wieder laufen
was machen wir jetzt wir machen
zwischenzeit machen wir folgendes
solange es hier drei mal einen kleinen
trick den habe ich gelernt als ich drei
jahre lang in den film auf ein kaufhaus
das verbracht habe und zwar machen wir
jetzt hier überall ein bisschen butter
rein sagt man kann es mit dem bug trend
spiel machen aber wenn es nicht jeder
hat da kann man einfach auf unternehmen
wir haben es hier rein getan und erst
ganz kurz in den backofen was sie gut
ist darf ich kurz rein gestellt
jetzt warten bis die butter schmilzt
in der zwischenzeit machen und trinken
bis jetzt nichts dazu gehört
ok
[Musik]
ich kann doch jetzt fertig muss raus
so wie kartoffeln sind jetzt geschält so
sehen sie aus ich jetzt noch länger drin
lassen können aber dann kann er
kartoffeln mehr übrig geblieben
deswegen ist es so in ordnung jetzt
machen der nächste trick machen diesen
aufsatz drauf sag dann immer diese
kartoffel
jetzt lassen wir es schnell laufen
[Applaus]
da schneiden wir diese kartoffel einfach
hier für die hälfte oben rein
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit holen wir mal kurz
das backblech kraus
so hatten wir alles schön eingebettet
als nächstes holen wir uns die
schlagschüsse
und zwar einen schlag lösen und zwar
nehmen wir diese schlagschüsse nichts
nicht zu verwechseln mit dem schlagring
hier ist die schüssel und hier tut mir
jetzt die ganzen kartoffelscheiben rein
als nächstes sich schon warum werden die
erste problem
nasse hände also mit nassen händen keine
nachricht anziehen was man nicht alles
so voller kamera um hygienisch zu wirken
so perfekt das reicht vollkommen aus
jetzt können wir folgendes machen es
waren um folgendes jetzt nehmen wir
dieses salz und zwar ist es im knoblauch
salz und knoblauch pfeffer kräuter
seiten an knoblauch salz hätte einfach
nur noch salz aus norwegen oslo bin ja
fragt nicht wie das ding hier gefunden
hat aber das ist richtig cool dann
richtig tolles knoblauch salz das reicht
schon
dann nehmen wir griechen thymian der ist
das omas garten ist rosmarie schon kann
s nicht verwechseln das grün ja ist grün
genau deswegen weil es eine auch grüne
sorgt da man das mal hier drin ist hier
richtig richtig ist die das abnehmen
ganz trimmel ok folgendes jetzt nämlich
parmesan parmesan bitte immer am stück
kaufen wer geriebenen parmesan schon
fertig kauft erwirbt auch kleine wunde
welt - kalte wasser deswegen sachen
gibst du aha so rum geht es nicht
schlecht jetzt ein bisschen parmesan
reiben das richtig kohle rein ich liebe
parmesankäse und zwar im leben parmesan
ist meistens trennmittel drin
das haben wir ja nicht richtig frisch
klingt es einfach so als nächstes nehmen
wir die hände und tun es richtig
zusammen zu manchen jetzt habe ich was
vergessen und zwar ein bisschen olivenöl
kann ich ein bisschen olivenöl haben nur
so ein schluck und zwar nicht so recht
zum ansaugen nur einen schluck
jawohl das reicht schon
und jetzt zumindest alles wissen von
manchen kommen braucht es appetitlich
aussieht es aus wie jamie oliver geht es
nach minute wahnsinn oder
ja stimmt eigentlich da hättest du von
dir natürlich das von mir ich hab so
richtig schön rum gemacht aber das macht
richtig spaß bis jetzt ein handschuhe
aus diese handschuhe
dann werde ich das waschen wieder
verwenden also nicht geben wenn jemand
sagt ich kann schon wieder sprechen
schwiegereltern
dann habe ich diese scheiben hier und
diese scheiben legt jetzt wunderschön
hier reiten ich nehme es mein handy ist
mir egal
die linken jetzt richtig schön rein und
wie sieht es aus wahnsinn oder fordernd
strich durch die hier arbeiten schwabe
kann man ja mal ein glas bringt das
jetzt nur aus trinken kann und jetzt
dass wir nach das ist das richtig
richtig cool verbindet nämlich jetzt
noch ein richtig coolen café keese und
zwar dieser kascha das ist so ein
türkischer käse jetzt sagen die bulgaren
eder spielerisch und und da habe ich
eigentlich nichts entgegenzusetzen
doch erst tätig und den cut mache ich
drauf der ich nicht zu arg wird sich
wieder parmesan aber eine richtig tolle
schmelz eigenschaft dass und das klebt
nachher da klebt nachhaltig ganzen
kartoffelscheiben kleben zusammen
genauso wie es haben wollte und da habe
ich kurz im gefrierschrank gehabt dann
lässt sich richtig toll reiben und jetzt
immer noch richtig cool im pfeffer und
dem tepper natürlich auch immer frisch
gemahlen ja nicht fertig gekauft kaufen
als pulver
da müssen sie nämlich immer alles rein
und so entfaltet sich der geschmack
richtig wo ich es weiß ich habe meinen
kopf sendung angeschaut hat genau das
gesagt
jetzt sehen wir dass hier wohl und tut
sie den backofen tom sack rein und jetzt
wird es cool das wollen wir euch
folgendes das ist für für männer gedacht
dieser backofen sondern immer auf dem
menü auf menü auf die assist funktion
dann machen wir einen auflauf wegen der
form haben wir auch läufe sondern aus
der kartoffel gratin flach drücken ist
auch drauf und jetzt wurde es im park
auf minister heim das hier nicht haben
dann tut es einfach auf umluft 160 grad
für eine stunde und das ist jetzt meine
einstellung des weißen backofen
der misst alles da die zahlen beim stoß
und laura solche tollen sachen ist
erklärlich mal die sally und hier als
tipp steht dem gefäß auf brusthöhe 2002
eingestellt und jetzt einfach statt und
ist erst mal eine stunde richtig drin
gehört jetzt ist ein dampf stoß jetzt
wird es nämlich außen saftig und innen
und außen richtig cross in der
zwischenzeit freuen wenn wir den
gesamten team alle zusammen hier alles
auf weil hier sieht's aus wie als
headliner ja jemand gekocht ok alles da
los
so also ich muss jetzt raus ich nehme
alles ist fertig wahnsinn oder ist
jedoch riesig aber lecker waren sie
nicht ausgelöst und riss auch sehr genau
hier sieht man kriegt so eine speise
auch hin mit geringem bildungsniveau man
braucht nur die technik ja auf jeden
fall
ich habe ja schon und teller was sie
jetzt auch mal erwähnen möchte das
rezept ist vielleicht nicht gerade
gesund ich glaube das gesündeste an dem
rezept ich wahrscheinlich die die titel
und schicht der marke in form ich
wahrscheinlich gesunde steht hier dran
aber es schmeckt okay ich hab so
hingekriegt so aber es war das erste mal
fast verheilt gut eingelebt ja ich habe
es ein gebot okay des problems zweite
mal ob ich beim zweiten mal den krieg
das ist einfach nicht bis oben hin
gefüllt kann das sein
ja ich hab's nicht bis oben hin gefüllt
oder weiteres und jetzt denke ich mir
immer die teflon beschichtung ist
eigentlich auch ganz gut okay aber es
ist nicht so dass wir es uns einfach aus
der maschine verbraucht ja bestimmt also
normalerweise funktioniert ist ich habe
es auch zum ersten mal gemacht aber ich
habe mir gesteckt wahnsinn oder
fernsehen kommt auch dass ich mein
glückstag perfekt ich will es probieren
sli ja ich probiere auch das kahnbein
cache einstellungen genau auxilion text
hallo ich ehrlich sein also ist auch
nicht schmeckt dann sagst wirklich ich
bin ihr nicht böse hat sich da jetzt
alles drin also dass in kartoffeln drin
pelzer kartoffeln dann ist knoblauch
salz thymian dann haben wir paris oder
parmesan reingemacht dann haben wir
haben keine reingemacht so passt doch
dass ehrlichkeit
das auch nicht demoralisieren weil sonst
keiner wie sie heute habe ich nicht
verraten dass das tanzen war ja aus
liebe okay und ich wollte ich nicht
demotivieren
man sagt ja auch zu einem kind nicht
ständig du kannst nicht lesen sondern
man fördert das kind und bestärkt das ja
und lobt das kind damit einfach die
motivation nicht verliert hast du hast
sehr gut gekocht vielen dank dafür
es ist nicht klar wie schon auf weitere
rezepte also glaube ich mein kind ok
also nächstes nächste woche mache ich
dann wahrscheinlich ein motiv tore also
freuen uns drauf und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten monat fünf minuten kommt jetzt
noch mal bis dann tschüss auf eine coole
beilage ja es war eine hauptspeise ja
völlig okay so ist das kind auch zu
greifen
[Musik]